sony blick fragt wann hat mario vor
jasko mal zum trainieren zu motivieren
ich versuche das schon die ganze zeit
den jasko zum training zu motivieren
der erste hat aber eine gute genetik auf
jeden fall sein kleiner bruder das mein
trainingspartner und ja das schwester
warum lässt du dich nicht motivieren ich
wirklich bin ich spritzen so ganz klar
also der ist gott ein problem anstatt
mich anscheinend mit steroiden deswegen
allein andere qualitäten von mir runter
weiß wie gut steroiden okay wie sie ist
der will ich weiß auch nicht mehr
du kannst mir eine idee gegeben unter
irgendeinem facebook post kannst du mir
ein kommentar oder schreib mal alle
kommentare wie ich den animieren kann
zum training ich weiß langsam ohne
arbeit
wenn du mir sagst du bringst ihnen jeden
tag eine frau mit zum fitnessstudio dann
komme ich mit ok das sollen die farid
bang fragt nicht der original verrät
sein vermute ich mal weil sonst würde er
diese frage nicht stellen
farid bang möchte wissen sind die video
blogs gespielt oder ist alles echt
lieber verrät die frage kannst du dich
selber beantworten
die video blog sind nicht gespielt weil
wir haben wir haben damit schon vor drei
vier monaten angefangen also das ist ein
längerer zeitraum wussten wir das
konzept des albums sein wird und wir
haben uns zu alle zwei wochen mal
verarscht und deswegen hat eine andere
das kurzzeitig vergessen und konnte
verarscht werden so wenn man das tag für
tag gemacht hätten dann wäre das ganze
möglich gewesen umut babo und boostedt
folgende frage wie ist der kontakt zur
fahrbahn standen der vaart hat uns mal
bei facebook geschrieben und hat gesagt
dass er unsere musik videos feiert und
sich gerne mal mit uns treffen würde wir
haben uns an einen tisch gesetzt und
sind direkt auf einen nenner gekommen
und das hat alles super harmoniert und
sind wir schon zwei jahre dabei fast
zwei jahre dabei
läuft alles prima sind die nets bis
hallo ihr beiden ist ein soloalbum von
einem von euch beiden geplant oder wird
es nur mario und jasko geben das steht
noch alles in den sternen geschrieben
wir sind noch erst mit diesem album
beschäftigt und bestimmt wird es
irgendwann mal solo projekte geben und
japan
die mir möchte wissen wie habt ihr euch
kennengelernt
also war nichts besonderes eigentlich in
der schule fünfte klasse haben uns
kennengelernt
durch die schlägerei das war das einzig
besondere also waren erstmal
kontrahenten immer deutschland auf der
anderen seite und bevor das eskaliert
ist damit einer der hat geschlichtet und
dadurch sind folgen für die dicksten
freunde geworden und da unser ganzes
leben
da unser ganzes leben auf konkurrenz
aufgebaut ist haben wir dieses album
this is just go genannt